well we were confident um we didn't
think they were a great side except for
maradona um and we didn't actually do
anything special only to say
whoever's closest to him uh try and
close him down and not let him
start getting a run on anything because
he's obviously a tremendous player
running with the ball and can influence
the game and
we did that brilliant in the first half
it was very close game not a lot of
chances
and the game changed on its head so to
speak seven minutes into the second half
with the
the famous hand of god goal when um
maradona
uh cheated putting it in with his hand
and uh of course you know he celebrated
uh
kept looking around i think because he's
expecting the referee to give
give a foul to us and uh of course the
referee and lies me and i
were very very poor in the game uh
didn't give it and
we went one nil down which was a very
crucial moment in that tie because it
was the first goal and
and of course he scored a fantastic goal
four minutes later
it was one of those moments that people
remember and and i think
listen a lot of people have cheated in
football but in a quarterfinal world cup
obviously diego maradona got away with
it and um
you know it was one of those moments
will will be remembered
i think it was a little bit more from an
english point of view
uh about after the game because you know
most players especially if his caliber
and statue
would probably have said look yeah i did
cheat i got away with it
um yeah i apologize you know i'm not
it's not going to make a difference to
the result we're we're through to the
semi-finals but
but he never did that he came out with a
quote of hand of god and
uh and a lot of well the team really
felt a little bit grieved by it really
to be fair
and it left a sour taste but you know
time's gone by i mean i've had
opportunities to
myself to meet him and and as you said
look if he's prepared to
apologize you know then we shake hands
and and move on but that never happens
so
it's never going to happen and i think
we need to draw a line under it now and
uh
appreciate him obviously as a great
player
well of course you know his life off off
the pitch was uh
you know was what's the right word i'm
not sure i mean it was
a little bit chaotic he obviously had
health issues um
you know but he you know i spoke to
people who said he was a real character
you know a lot of people people loved
him you know he had that sort of uh
down-to-earth atmosphere let's be fair
he you know he came from very humble
beginnings and
you know he probably didn't learn a lot
about life when he was a youngster's
uh well as far as i'm saying he's he's
the greatest player i played against and
um you know forgetting the the hand of
god and the blip and
and the cheating side of it you know he
was he was
he was superb player i mean um pele
who i never played against but i
obviously um
was a i was at that age very young when
i i managed to
be on the bench for england and see him
play he was he
and them two together for me were the
greatest players of all time and
uh yes you know and i think maradona um
you know he won the world cup for me for
argentina in that tournament on his own
i mean you know the ability to
to dribble past people you know three or
four players at a time
he didn't just do it once he did it many
times
and you don't see that anymore in the
modern game you know it's all past past
pass
he he was uh he was a one-off
and a football genius